[Music]
[Applause]
uh steve palazzolo the co-host pro
football focus the nfl podcast you can
check out the podcast and go to
profootballfocus.com there uh sale going
on on elite subscriptions a great gift
for the holiday season and uh the promo
code is elite up there to take advantage
of that steve joins us now steve uh you
do this for a living where you're
grading players and looking at all the
film uh what kind of season is matthew
stafford having right now
uh this is great this was uh the season
that i predicted for him i thought i was
gonna lose it for a while but my
prediction was he was gonna
grade in our system in a similar manner
as he did in previous seasons which for
us was low 80s uh which is good very
good quarterback but i predicted that
his uh production would be a lot better
in that system with uh with the great
receivers that he have i didn't know
cooper copp was going to be as good as
he's been this year but i figured the
system and the supporting cast would
would increase stafford's production i
think we're seeing that stafford has
been good this season had a couple of
those rough games in the middle the
turnovers uh the sunday night football
game against tennessee but overall
stafford has uh he's made some big plays
he's missed a few open throws had some
turnover worthy throws but i think these
last few weeks we're seeing the big time
throws that they got him for right the
50-yarder a couple weeks ago to van
jefferson uh special throws into tight
coverage so overall i think stafford is
having one of the better years of his
career but not as good as maybe the
passer rating of 108 and you know most
productive passing offense in the league
i don't think he's been that good but
he's been good and the supporting cast
has helped elevate his game even further
is he a top 10 quarterback this year
uh yeah we have a number seven overall
as a passer so yeah he's he's in that
top he's definitely in that top 10 range
right now especially in a year where
there haven't really been there hasn't
really been elite quarterback play
across the nfl nobody's really standing
out so stafford's got they've got the
best passing production in the league
and he's at number seven in our passing
grade so far this year now rogers has
been pretty elite
yeah i think i think people are
forgetting a couple of rogers games in
here because uh week one he had that
game against the saints where he was
terrible they lost 38-3 it was i mean it
was pretty much the same thing we just
saw from tom brady the other night it
just happened you know months ago so i
think people forget it and honestly the
game they won 17 to nothing against the
seattle seahawks he was just as bad
through an end zone interception he was
he was not good in that particular game
so rogers has had a few duds and he has
not been i don't think as good throw up
the throws he was last year in that mvp
season yeah but 30 touchdowns four
interceptions that's an off year
no i get it he also has 12 turnover
worthy plays because again we tracked
this stuff so he's got far but he's
usually he's look he's one of the best
in the league wait wait that's explain
that steve turn over worthy
so we're we're grading every player in
every play so we're going in there and
saying if you misread the play and throw
the ball two-way linebacker say uh
whether or not the linebacker catches
the ball it's a bad play right if it's
cod it's an interception if it's not
it's the same bad play so rodgers has
gotten away with a few of those plays
this year more than usual he's still one
of the best at taking care of the ball
but that's why i don't always look
directly at touchdown interception ratio
because in this particular case rogers
interception totals uh it's lying a
little bit this year i think compared to
previous seasons
i don't know what to make of jalen hurts
i find him a a valuable weapon
and but i i don't know unless
philadelphia embraces him like baltimore
did with lamar jackson
then it feels like that question is
always going to loom there with him is
he the right quarterback franchise
quarterback how do you grade jalen hurts
because it's it what he gives you is not
normal from quarter you know
quarterbacks perspective
yeah you know i think it took them a few
weeks to figure out they need to play
this style football and now that style
of football being this team that can run
for 150 200 yards every single week and
use jalen hurts in the design running
game they had games earlier this year
where it was just throw throw throw and
look i'm a past game enthusiast i love
that but when you have a jalen hurts a
run a quarterback who brings value in
the design running game um is it's
pumped to defend and i think you see a
game like last night where jalen hurts
is used in the design run game it opens
things up for the running backs you run
play action off of that
you can win with that in this in the nfl
right you could do that and then this
what do you make of jalen hurts the
tough part is going to be
do you want to sign him long term right
has he done enough there i think
he's good on a rookie contract right you
could do some cool stuff on a ricky
contract building this great roster
around him don't necessarily know if i
want to lock him up long term we're
still a little over a year into his
career so hey he can improve so in other
words he said he's a good enough passer
and in playing that style opens up
throws lamar jackson has more open
throws than other quarterbacks because
the defense has to account for him and
that wrestling attack and it creates
open receivers jalen hurts brings that
to the table as well so you can mitigate
some of the maybe lack of polish in the
pocket that jalen hurts has is carson
once a positive or a negative for the
colts
can i say neutral he's neutral i mean
he's a he's a league average quarterback
and he has for a while i think he's been
more positive than negative this year
though he's generally taking care of the
ball um he did not take care of the ball
on saturday night against the patriots
he was uh pretty bad in that game and
they got away with it but overall uh you
take away the the game in the with the
river reign you know in sunday night
football against the niners carson wentz
has done a really nice job of taking
care of the ball and when you do that
when you have the colt offensive line
and jonathan taylor you can win some
games right and they've scored a ton of
points they've got michael pittman
emerging wence does get the ball to him
pretty well so i think it's been more
positive than negative but i don't think
wentz is out there
carrying the team or anything like he
did say in 2017. yeah but when you say
boy he takes care of the ball that
doesn't have a
franchise quarterback sound to it should
the colts be in the market for another
quarterback an upgrade
yeah i don't know how they're gonna be
challenged with that contract and
everything but i'm i'm generally of the
mind unless you have one of say the top
eight quarterbacks in the league and
defining those
probably harder than ever harder than it
was you know five or six years ago if
you don't have one of those guys i think
you're always in the market because
yeah you want a guy that can elevate
those around you not do what i just
described taking care of the ball and
relying on everyone else to kind of
carry you
the seahawks offense is not good because
what
why who
they have uh shane waldron's the new
offensive coordinator and they just
they've been early in the season they're
a little top heavy ross makes those
special throws down the field a couple
times a game overall it looks efficient
they're just play-by-play
they're not good it's the intermediate
level of the field that they're not
attacking so i think there's a little
bit of play calling there's a little bit
of russell wilson in there that 10 to 19
yard range in this new offense just has
been non-existent so it's been a bunch
of short passes
russ hits a couple of bombs over the top
and then you have a game like last night
when he doesn't hit those palms this
offense is terrible um so it's it's just
too there's not enough high percentage
quality plays in this offense and i
think that's a combination of uh shane
waldron as offensive coordinator this
new system just not meshing with russell
wilson's skill set and plus rosa
wilson's just not playing nearly as well
as he did for the majority of last year
2018 the rest of his career uh whether
that's partly the finger injury
we're just not seeing the same russell
wilson for the most part this season
how do you rank rate cooper cups season
man it's it's incredible i mean i think
you know he's he's got that triple crown
of receptions and yards and touchdowns
and everything but
um
he is just he's good at everything right
and he's great after the catch he's good
at getting open against man coverage
he's got a great feel for zone him and
matthew stafford have just had an
incredible connection as far as being on
the same page so cup's been the best
he's best receiver in the league this
year but if somebody hadn't seen cooper
cup play
how would you describe him
i would say he's like the he's an uber
slaw receiver who took his game from
gets open underneath and you know has a
good feel for the game
it's taking his game to the next level
where you can't leave him one-on-one and
he can win at every level of the field
like the best receivers can
and then the rams put him in good
position to succeed as well so very good
all-around receiver does everything well
sure handed great after the catch
creates big plays but
is he devante adams category is he a
healthy deandre hopkins category or
you know there's quite a few great
receivers but cooper cup is
is having one of the greatest seasons of
all time
i think he's a step below those guys
because you do have you do have a
built-in advantage when you're in the
slot right so and that's where he does
most of his work um i don't think you
just drop cooper cup in the green bay's
offense and say hey go be devonte adams
right go beat uh
man coverage as often as you do so he's
a step below those true outside x
receivers but it's one of the best slot
receiver seasons of all time which is
you know technically a little bit easier
but at this level of production you know
cooper thought it's definitely a special
season i see what you said you know step
a step below here it comes down to 40
yard dash time i see what you're doing
steve
i'm just a speed guy you'll be able to
be all the fast guys is lamar jackson
improving
no he's not
uh earlier this season
i may have said yes but the last few
weeks you know prior to his injury were
pretty bad and it was
um a lot of decision making stuff right
it was uh a lot of just him throwing
into coverage and
the curious part here is i think he's
got his best group of playmakers that
he's had in his entire career you know
with marquis brown breaking out with
rashad bateman there with sami watkins
and what mark andrews mark anderson
continued to take his game to the next
level
this should have been
not maybe the best statistical season
for lamar because
nvp season was great but this should
have been a much better season for lamar
jackson and i think the last few weeks
he's uh he's taken a step back in his
development where he's just not seeing
the field very well
the packers chiefs grayed out as the two
best teams right now
yeah i think i mean i think trending
wise to you know the the chiefs defense
um i think they went on a run i don't i
still don't know that they're
necessarily championship caliber i think
the chief's offense has shown flashes of
being what they were before but they
will
uh they're not
exactly where they were but it's
dangerous enough and i think the packers
part of the intrigue with the packers is
maybe david bakiri is going to come back
maybe you know jerry alexander is going
to come back at some point the packers
last year i think were very reliant on
just aaron rodgers and devonte adams and
jair like the top heavy roster they're
able to win in other ways now we're guys
like rasul douglas and devondre campbell
stepping up on defense so i love the way
the packers are trending and they're
getting other good players back so yeah
i think the top two seats packers and
chiefs are the two best teams in the nfl
right now
thank you steve as always merry
christmas thanks for joining us my best
everybody at pro football focus
thank you dan merry christmas to you and
all the viewers that's uh steve
palazzolo